- One of our panelists,
Max Price in South Africa,
was unable to fly here
to be with us today,
but he has recorded
his presentation,
which we will see.
And he will join us
live via video feed
from Cape Town during
the question and answer.
And so, we're still taking the
cards for question and answer.
Our moderator for this panel
is Alejandro de la Fuente.
And he is the Robert
Woods Bliss Professor
of Latin American
history and economics
and professor of
African American studies
and history at Harvard.
He's also the director of the
Afro-Latin American Research
Institute, and the co-chair
of the Cuban Studies Program
at Harvard--
Alejandro.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Evelyn.
And thank you all for staying
for a Friday afternoon--
a beautiful Friday
afternoon, in fact.
I want to take a second to
say thank you to the faculty
organizers of this
magnificent conference,
and thank you to Dean
Cohen and her staff
for hosting this event.
I am particularly
pleased to be here
and to be part of this panel
on universities and slavery
globally, because as a
scholar of race and slavery
in Latin America, I very much
hope that this conference
and that these conversations
will resonate in the region.
Of course, connections between
universities or institutions
of higher learning and slavery
are not just a US phenomenon.
We heard, actually, a lot about
that in the previous panel.
And by the time
Harvard was created,
a dozen universities already
existed in the Americas.
Starting with the
first of them--
the Universidad Santo Tomas
de Aquino in Espanola in 1538.
And each of these institutions--
Santo Domingo, Quito,
Lima, Mexico, La Paz--
all of them were built
by African slaves.
Yet this conversation has not
really begun in Latin America.
And that, to me, is by itself
a very interesting question.
In fact, if you do a
search in Spanish--
universidades y esclavitud--
universities and slavery--
you will get a few hits.
But they speak about
Brown University.
They speak about
the Yale University.
They speak about Georgetown, not
about Santo Domingo or Havana.
I'm also pleased
to see this panel,
because Harvard's own
relationship with slavery,
of course, lasted
much longer than 1783,
as the previous panel
also made very clear.
And I was thinking about
the paper about Soledad,
about the Cuban plantation.
And being Cuban myself,
we all know that Soledad
was operated by slaves.
And we also know that the
botanical garden was somehow
linked to Harvard.
That knowledge exists.
But there is a big
difference between knowledge
and acknowledgement, right?
The knowledge is there, but
somehow the urgent questions
that we are trying
to deal with here
are not felt in some
of these places.
To lead us into
this conversation,
we are joined by three
distinguished panelists.
We will start with Vice
Chancellor of the University
of Cape Town, Max Price.
As Evelyn said,
Professor Price could not
be here with us today, but we
do have a recorded presentation.
And he will be joining us via
live feed from South Africa,
if technology helps.
We are also joined here--
and I am honored to have met--
Congresswoman and
former Minister
of Justice Madame
Christiane Taubira.
And we are also joined
here by Vice Chancellor
of the University of West
Indies, a renowned scholar
of slavery in the Caribbean,
Sir Hilary Beckles.
And we will start with the
presentation of Vice Chancellor
Max Price.
- Good afternoon.
It's a privilege to
have been invited
to participate in this panel
on slavery and universities.
I apologize that I
can't be with you.
It's our first week
of the academic year.
And as Vice Chancellor,
I needed to be here,
at the University of Cape Town.
Let me start by saying
that while South Africa has
a history of slavery,
it was abolished
when slavery was abolished
across the British empire
in 1834.
And the universities
in South Africa
were almost all established
long after that.
The University of Cape Town was
started as a college in 1929,
but in truth, there is
very little direct link
with slavery.
The only link currently
is that, as part of some
renovations that we
did on the campus,
we uncovered a slave graveyard
from the 18th century.
And we have built a
memorial to the slaves,
partly as a way of
recognizing people
who used to live on this
land before it became
the university, and partly--
and most importantly-- as an
educational tool for students
today to learn more
about the history.
Given that limited
impact of slavery
on the University
of Cape Town, you
might well ask, as I
did of President Faust
when she invited me to
participate in this colloquium,
why it was thought I would
have something to contribute
or why the University
of Cape Town
might have something
to contribute.
I presume it is because of the
parallel and analogous events
and student movements
that have forced
us to take a hard look at
how the university was built
upon and embodied
the values, not
of slavery but of
colonialism and apartheid.
Those protests have
forced us to assess
the extent to which the
institutional culture
today still reflects
and reproduces
those colonial values, and to
confront how that environment
today offends and alienates
the descendants of those
who are oppressed,
disenfranchised, and excluded.
But yet today, those descendants
are present on our campus.
Not only are they
present, they actually
form the majority of the
students on our campus.
These student-led
protests started at UCT
with the campaign to remove
the iconic statue of Cecil John
Rhodes.
This campaign started
off similar campaigns
on other campuses across
the country, and in fact,
around the world.
The so-called hashtag roads must
fall campaign, in some sense,
has led this battle charge.
Rhodes was the perfect
symbol of this problem.
A supreme colonialist,
he was on the one hand
a generous benefactor,
having gifted
to the nation the land on which
the university is now built,
and of course, many
other commitments--
financial commitments
to education
of future generations.
He was also a remarkable
businessman, a diplomat,
a politician, and ultimately
the prime minister
of the Cape colony.
Yet on the other hand, he was
responsible for conquering
and annexing land
for the empire,
was ultimately responsible
for military massacres,
particularly in what
is now Zimbabwe--
exploited labor on the mines
through the manipulative use
of legislation, which
forced people off the land
into the cash economy, and
perhaps most importantly,
removed the vote from
many black people
in the Cape colony
who previously
had the right to vote.
Partly because the university
is built on the land he gifted,
he was nevertheless
honored in the 1930s
with a large, breeding
bronze statue, positioned
in the central focal point of
the architecture on the campus.
No other significant
statues of individuals
exist on the campus.
Thus it would seem that UCT was
honoring Rhodes, presenting him
as a role model, and someone
who embodies the values of UCT.
While for many students if
they cared to know something
about Rhodes and the
history, the statue
represented the victory
over the colonized masses,
revering a man who had
deprived their ancestors
of numerous different rights--
rights to land, to the
vote, and even to life.
Although the statue
was never intended
to be a tool of exclusion,
that's what it had become.
The campus could not
be considered inclusive
while it stood in its
prominent position.
After a month of
consultation and debate,
in 2015, the Senate
and the Council--
which is the governing
body of the university--
agreed that it
should be removed.
But it was not only
about the statue--
far from it.
The statue symbolized
the colonial culture,
that through the
statue the university
continued to valorize.
The university
does, indeed, have
its roots in the
colonial era, and is
modeled on the Oxbridge
models of universities.
You look at the architecture
of UCT, of the university,
and it tells you
something about what
the university aspires to be.
If you walk through the
passages of the departments
of the university,
the walls are lined
by portraits and photographs of
previous heads of departments,
professors, and deans,
almost all of whom,
not surprisingly,
are white males.
The buildings and
rooms of the university
are mostly named after
white males, some of whom
were academics, some of
whom were benefactors,
and some of whom were
political leaders
from the colonial period.
In the curricula, there is
often little or no recognition
of thought leadership
that comes from societies
other than Western civilization
or that other civilizations
have contributed to some of
the collective canon that
is what we today consider
the sum of human knowledge.
The curriculum often
rejects or refuses
to recognize the validity
of other belief systems--
say, for example,
in health sciences,
belief systems about
the role that ancestors
play in one's health.
The message that students
construct about the attitudes
and values of the university
is derived, therefore,
from what is reflected
back to them--
back from the walls,
back from the curricula,
back from the role models
they have as lecturers
and professors, what
is reflected back
to them as examples
of excellence,
as examples of the culture
of the institution.
And what is reflected
is a white culture.
And so, for black
students, there
is a pervasive
sense of alienation.
And it is exacerbated by many
other experiences, such as how
people--
both black and white--
respond to other black people,
based on the stereotype
assumptions that they have
internalized, based on cues,
such as color, accent,
dress, and much more.
The choice of artworks
and sculptures
on display in public places is
another source of alienation.
Some students come from
cultures where nudity--
especially of older people--
is considered so disrespectful
towards older people
that they will not
bring their children
to see their workplace,
because they do not
want to have to explain why
such nudity is on display.
And then they challenge
us with the question,
how is this an inclusive campus
if I cannot bring my children
to work?
Artworks that were created--
say, 40 years ago during
the apartheid period--
depicting the wretchedness of
black life under apartheid.
Often, these were courageous
political statements
at the time, some of the
works by black artists
and photographers.
But these today, ironically,
may be regarded out of context
as simply a further repetition
of the black person's typical
and even expected
station in life.
There are no whites depicted
this way in these artworks
and photographs.
So the young black student,
born post-apartheid,
does not see this as an
anti-apartheid statement.
She sees this as a statement
about the university,
and how the university--
and how white people--
view black people
as an underclass.
These are the issues
that have been
dominant on our campus
over the last two years,
in the equivalent
of what in the US
are the Black Lives Matter
campaigns, which here tend
to take the form of
arguments about coloniality
and decolonization.
And these are the issues that
we have needed to address.
So what have we done?
We have initiated a
number of interventions
to begin to address
the concrete elements
of the environment
that are signaling
this exclusive colonial culture.
Transformation is therefore
no longer primarily
about racial demography, though
that remains an unfulfilled
challenge, especially
in the level of faculty.
Now transformation
is about changing
the institutional culture.
It is also more than just
recognizing and representing
the different heritages of
those who now constitute
the new university community,
such as through naming
buildings after struggle heroes
or in indigenous languages.
It is more about
removing and changing
the names of buildings
that honor people
who were oppressors,
even if they may only
be regarded that way in the
light of today's value systems.
It is about revealing
artworks that cause offense,
and either contextualizing
them adequately-- if possible--
or placing them in galleries
rather than in public
places, where people can
choose to view them or not.
It is about rethinking the
pageantry of ceremonies,
such as graduation
or commencements,
to reflect less
colonial traditions
and incorporate local
traditions and music.
Perhaps the hardest
intervention is
engaging with the
challenges of what
some consider "epistemic
violence," quote, unquote--
the nature of knowledge and
pedagogy in higher education.
This may refer to curricular
content, such as including
intellectual contributions
from non-western and especially
African thinkers, to teaching
about indigenous belief systems
as part of co-curricular
in some professions,
to ways of learning
and teaching.
The extent of such
curriculum decolonization
will vary by discipline and
profession, and much of this
is still notional and unformed.
It cannot be imposed
on academics.
They have to be persuaded
to take up the challenge,
to listen seriously to
the concerns of those
who feel marginalized, and who
feel that the curriculum does
not speak to them, and to
seek out these problems
and find ways of
addressing them.
At core, in
transformation, therefore,
is a change in attitude to
what is meant by inclusiveness.
Previously, we meant by
inclusiveness helping newcomers
adapt to and succeed in
the institution as it is,
with its historic culture.
This entailed removing
barriers, affirmative action,
academic support, bridging
programs, acculturation,
writing skills--
essentially, becoming
more like us,
more like the historically
dominant group.
The newcomer was expected
to fit in, to assimilate,
and we would do
everything to assist that.
Post-grads must fall.
Inclusiveness means changing
the culture of the institution,
too, to reflect the different
cultures, and heritages,
and values of those who
constitute its community.
It is actually a change in our
identity as an institution.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good evening.
Good afternoon to each of you.
I'd like to spend a few
seconds to tell you how pleased
I am being here with you.
At the critical time
of the world life--
so critical time.
I'd like to thank Mrs.
President, Mrs. Drew Gilpin
Faust, and Mrs. Dean.
Lizabeth Cohen for
this invitation,
because it's very
important for me
to share with you our thoughts,
our works, our prospects
about certain sensitive matter
as slavery and universities.
That means slavery
and knowledge, slavery
and ethical matters.
At this very beginning
of this statement,
I think it is important for
me to make clear two points.
First of this point-- because
I'm going to speak about
the French experience--
first of this point is that
during the time where France
was involved in slave
trade and slavery,
this slavery was not practiced
on its own territory.
You know what was the
so-called Triangular Trade?
You know the facts.
It was a very
lucrative activity.
The facts are that boats
leaving European harbor
carrying different
kinds of goods,
reaching the African
coast, and then dealers
could buy these woman,
these men, these children,
who were captured in their
villages, in the cities,
all over the African continent.
And then these boats cross what
became a huge, deep cemetery,
the Atlantic Ocean.
Where are your
monuments, your martyrs?
Where is your tribal memory?
Souls in that grave of the sea.
The sea has locked them up.
The sea is history.
That's a part of a poem of
Derek Walcott, a Saint Lucian
Caribbean poem, Caribbean poet.
The sea is history.
And so, once arrived in
America and the Caribbean
islands, the same boats
unloaded from and chain people.
These people were driven to the
slave market to be sold again.
In the same boat,
the same boats were
loaded with sugar, coffee,
coco, gold, silver, spices,
tobacco, and so forth, and
is sent back to Europe.
That was this Triangular Trade.
And it was the way it
worked during four centuries
as a rule.
I said to you that it's
a very important point
to understand that
slavery was not practiced
on the own territory of France.
So, for French people,
slave trade and slavery
is something very far.
It's just trade.
It's something colonial, unless
for philosophers, writers,
some workers, some citizens,
too, who protested against it.
They protested during the time
of slave trade and slavery.
But it was far.
And in the French
collective consciousness,
slave trade is
something far, far, far.
Slavery is kind of
colonial matter,
even maybe a private
one, although there
were public companies
settled and managed
by the power of the state.
So during this is
hard and very dark
period when slave trade
and slavery were practiced,
there was not a massive
physical presence in France.
So there was not a
massive confrontation.
It's a very important point.
The second important point
is that France is not
a federal country like the
United States of America.
France is a centralized country.
That means that political
or legal decision
applies on the spot and
all over the territory.
So when the French
Parliament voted
the law that settled that
slave trade and slavery is
a crime against humanity,
the law applies on the spot
all over the territory.
It took two years for the
bill I wrote to become a law,
arguing with the House
of Representatives
and the Senate. and the senate.
This law contains a solemn
and official proclamation
that slave trade and slavery
is a crime against humanity,
that slave trade
was not a trade.
It was a crime, and
not any kind of crime--
a crime against humanity.
That means the enslaved
people were not slaves.
They were not goods.
They were not materials.
They were not furnitures.
They were, they are woman,
man, children, human beings.
That's what this
proclamation means.
Other provisions of this
law deserve to be mentioned.
According to
Article 2, the state
is compelled to organize
the teaching of its history
in all public schools,
from primary to university.
In France, more than 80% of
the schools are public schools.
And the state is compelled to
encourage facilitate, support--
including financial--
research, cooperation
between universities,
between universities
and other institutions in
the country and abroad.
Article 3 founded a
national committee
for memory and
history of slavery.
This committee has
in charge all kind
of actions likely to make this
story well-known, better known
in the whole country.
And this committee, up
to now, give every year
a price on the order of
7,000 euros for a high level
work of a student.
Every year, there is another
prize for a scholar--
that means children
and teenagers--
called the flame of equality.
Every year or two, they
organize a big civic meeting.
They have in charge to
organize seminars and symposium
to lead relationship
with UNESCO and others.
And last year, for
instance, 150 events
were organized all
over the territory.
I must say that there was
an article in the bill
relevant to reparations.
After months and
months of polemics,
this article was removed, but
the debate is still there.
The following article sets
up a debt, a national debt,
for an official and
solemn ceremony.
The ceremony is shared
by the French president
of the republic.
It takes place in the
heart of Paris, the Jardin
de Luxembourg, and last
year, the guest of honer
was the Reverend Jesse Jackson.
And in the world
territory, there
are ceremonies--
local ceremonies
organized by sub-prefects.
Sub-prefects are high public
servants representing the state
all over the territory.
We have a different situation.
For instance, in Bordeaux,
it's also in 2009
that the first local
ceremony took place.
I must remember that two
years debating the law--
the bill before law.
The national committee
was set up only on 2004.
The first national
ceremony official
took place only on 2006,
and the first local ceremony
in Bordeaux in 2009.
But we have also a counter
example, such as Nantes.
Nantes is a big
city that tackles
with this story
since many years.
In 1985, for instance, Nantes--
when I say Nantes, I speak of
association and the city hall.
They organized an event
remembering the third century
of the Black Code.
The Black Code stipulated
that slave and enslaved
people were furnitures.
In 1992, Nantes
organized an event.
[FRENCH] talked about them.
[FRENCH] remembering
the fifth century
of Christopher Columbus'
journey in West Indies.
And in 2012, Nantes opened
this wonderful, beautiful, very
powerful memorial, very
important in the city.
So we have this counter example.
Anyway, we observes that
we faced push backs.
That means so
between historians,
but mainly I talked
about Bordeaux.
That is a big, rich
city, nice city
that was the second
important harbor--
French harbor
during slave trade.
Nantes was the first one.
And people pay attention to
the sociology of the city.
I mean, which is that professor,
teachers are very, very careful
not to upset the families whose
fortune comes from slave trade.
So it's a real break
against facing this history.
But we try to deal with that.
And even if we are
facing these push backs.
We keep working on it.
And more and more
people are involved
in this truth of the history,
and the way this history
has shaped the society
and the mentality.
So this example shows that
when, at the level of the state
of a country, the decision--
the courageous decision
is taken to recognize
a crime against humanity and
to take all the consequences
of this reconnection, its a
way to drive the whole society,
to tackle, to
grapple this history,
and to include it in
the day to day life.
So I will conclude considering
all these elements.
I remember some words
of James Baldwin.
James Baldwin was criticizing
what the President JFK--
John Fitzgerald Kennedy-- said.
It was on 1962.
He said it's quite
conceivable that in the United
States within 40 years, there
will be a black president.
And James Baldwin said for
people living at the present,
this far prospect
is unacceptable.
I'm concluding--
And he was right.
And the fact is that you
had a black president
more than 40 years later.
And it shows after the power
of this black president--
excuse me, but what a backlash.
What a backlash.
Anyway, this helps
us to understand
that opposition is not amazing.
It's not amazing at all.
We just have to remember
that it's about people.
So we are not
allowed to give up.
We must stand up, because
it's about people.
It's about broken
personal destinies.
It's just for money.
It's about people living
today, people hearing a nigger,
a bambula, a boy.
It's about people who are
shot with no reason but--
it's about the children.
Boys, girls, we are not
allowed to go to school.
We are working in
the plantations.
We are working in the house--
in the master's house,
serving the masters, the
mistress, the children
of the master, of the mistress.
It's about these people--
some of the people think
they have no predestination
to go to university
or to win Nobel Prize.
It's about children who
have no right of childhood.
So we can't give up.
We just can't give up.
We have to stand up for that.
In a poem Langston Hughes, the
title is "I Too Sing America."
Some say that it was
a sort of response
of Walt Whitman's poem.
It says I am the darker brother.
They send me to the
kitchen when company comes.
And I love, and I eat
well, and I grow strong.
I, too, sing America.
Maybe he's right.
Maybe we are the darker
brothers, the darker sisters.
But we are.
We just are.
We are.
That's what it's not about race.
It's not a racial topic.
It's not a racial matter.
It's a human one.
It's a social one.
It's an ethical one because
we are all created equal.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
It was a fact.
- Madame President, colleagues,
and friends, good afternoon,
everyone.
It is an honor to be a
part of this discourse,
this conversation, and to
speak from the perspective
of the Caribbean and to
give voice to my identity
as the Vice
Chancellor of the only
regional university
in the Caribbean,
the University of
the West Indies--
which, as you know, has
three landed campuses
in Jamaica, Barbados,
Trinidad and Tobago,
and university centers scattered
all across the region--
a university that has been a
part of this epic Caribbean
struggle against slavery
and colonization,
a part of this enlightenment
journey of Caribbean peoples
who have been very intolerant
and rebellious within
the context of this history,
whether from the traditions
of [NON-ENGLISH] that covered
the entire region through
to the Haitian Revolution where
the people of the Caribbean
were the first in this
hemisphere to uproot slavery,
remove it, and criminalize it.
Through to all of the other
revolutionary struggles
in the Caribbean for
justice and for democracy,
this university I lead is
a part of this history.
It originated in the workers'
revolution of the 1930s
where the people stood up
against British colonization,
demanded an end to
the colonial regime,
and stood up for democracy,
for social justice.
The British government
responded to this
by establishing a
University College, which
originated as a college of the
University of London in 1948.
So that is the nature of
the university's origin.
But by 1963, we had
de-colonized that relationship
and declared an
independent University
of the West Indies, independent
of the University of London.
The journey, of
course, is not over.
There are still colonial
relationships in the Caribbean.
There are still
colonies of France.
There are colonies of
America, colonies of England.
The majority of our societies,
yes, have been de-colonized,
but there are still some
outstanding communities
across the archipelago
that are still trapped
in the colonial relationship.
And everywhere, the
legacy of slavery
is not only immediate, but
very aggressive in its agency.
And so, for us, the entire
environment, the ecology
of our existence is surrounded
by these institutions rooted
in slavery, built
by slave owners--
whether they are
physical structures,
ideological structures.
We are still surrounded by it.
And for us, slavery
is not remote.
It is immediate, it is pressing.
There are still
people in our region
whose great grandparents were
born in a slavery circumstance.
But our campuses are located
in the most beautiful
environments.
This is an image, a Google
Map of the campus in Barbados.
As you can see, it's a beautiful
campus overlooking the ocean,
but surrounding a
cricket field, which
is the quintessential
British model of building
a campus with a cricket
field at its core.
That is a model derived from
the classical British tradition.
That is an image of
the Barbados campus
at Cave Hill, where I
had the pleasure to be
the provost there for 15 years.
This is an image of the Jamaica
campus-- the Mona campus,
the long beautiful
Queensway leading
into the heartland of the
campus with the magnificent Blue
Mountains of Jamaica
in the background.
But it's important
to realize, though,
that these beautiful
environments, these really
wonderful, charming, and
picturesque communities,
all of these campuses
are built on lands
that were slave plantations.
Here at Mona, the
beautiful Mona campus,
this was the lands
occupied by the Mona sugar
plantation, where hundreds
of enslaved peoples
toiled and were buried.
We have the list of all of
those enslaved persons who
were emancipated, the
British Act in 1833.
We have excellent documents
of all of these people
who were the last among the
enslaved on the Mona estate,
the land we now occupy as the
Mona campus of the university.
And as you can see
here from these images,
the vast majority of
these enslaved persons
were described as
Creole, that is,
born in Jamaica, as opposed
to imported from Africa.
It's a very long list.
And I will not go through this.
But our campus at Mona
is associated also
with all of the traditions
of crimes against humanity
that we are now treating with.
The indigenous peoples
who experienced a genocide
under the Spanish
colonial project,
they also lived on the land
that is now the Mona campus.
And here are some shacks.
These were buildings that were
constructed on the land that
became our campus, to house
those Jewish refugees who were
able to escape the Third Reich.
And these structures were
built to rehabilitate
some of those Jewish people
who fled through Gibraltar
and found their way into
the hands of the British.
The British took care of
them and brought them here
to this land site.
And there are many
prominent members
of the Jewish community
whose parents were actually
housed in these structures
before the structures evolve
into the university.
So we have the history
then on our Mona campus,
not only of indigenous slavery
but also African slavery,
and also, indeed, the Holocaust
against the Jewish community.
This is a structure that
was designed to accommodate
the Jewish refugee camp.
And here you can
see Jewish persons
in this facility
in the mid 1940s.
This is an image of
the campus chapel,
which was built by enslaved
persons, first as a sugar mill.
In the 18th century,
this was a mill
of the sugar estate, which was
dismantled and the stones were
brought from the Jamaican
countryside to the Mona campus
and reconstructed as a chapel--
so from a sugar mill, which
was destructive of the lives
of enslaved Africans, to a
Christian chapel of reflection.
These are some of
the ruins that still
exist on the campus, the
legacies of the slave estate.
But here is an
interesting image.
This is an image of the new
medical faculty complex, which
was constructed four years ago.
It's a beautiful facility
built on the campus,
because the university
campus here started
in 1948 as a medical faculty.
And some six years
later, we decided
to build a state of the art
teaching and research complex.
But while we were doing this--
so while we were getting
ready to do this,
something extraordinary
happened on the campus.
The contract was allocated.
A major Chinese
multinational firm
won the contract to
build this complex.
And they came on
the site and were
preparing to excavate
the foundations to do
what they had to do.
And guess what?
The bones began to
come up from the earth.
We then discovered
that this facility
was about to be constructed
on the burial ground
of the enslaved Africans.
And no one knew that this was
the site, the ceremonial site.
This was a site where
hundreds of Africans
were buried in unmarked
graves on the soil.
Of course, we had to
stop the construction.
We did all of the excavations.
We removed all of the
bones of these ancestors.
We took them out.
We did what was necessary
and what was appropriate,
and then we constructed
a memorial on the site.
And there you can
see Danny Glover,
who was a part of
that conversation.
And here, now, we
have a memorial
with the names of all
of the enslaved Africans
that we were able to find--
in the records on this monument.
I moved to the Barbados
campus, the Barbados campus
at Cave Hill, also built on a
slave plantation-- or a series
of slave plantations.
Celebrating the 50th
anniversary of this campus,
four years ago, we carried
out a major analysis--
a historical analysis
of the community that
now constitutes the campus.
We were able to identify
all of those-- or most
of those enslaved
Africans who were
on that land that
is now the Cave Hill
campus of the university.
This is a major publication
that sets out this history.
And here is a monument
on the campus,
on the periphery of the campus
overlooking the Caribbean
Ocean.
And this monument is
called Quaw's Quest.
Why Quaw?
We discovered that in 1793,
a three-year-old child
from the Congo was sold
into slavery in Barbados
on the auction
blocks in Bridgetown
and was bought by the owner
of the land, which we now
occupy as our campus.
The gentleman who
bought the young Quaw,
he had a three-year-old
white child
and he wanted a
toy for his child.
And so, he bought Quaw.
Quaw grew up on this
land, and it was soon
discovered that he was a
remarkable and phenomenal
child.
And so, he acquired literacy
through his own efforts.
And at the emancipation
in 1834, we
discover that Quaw
is now a teacher
of children on the estate.
The Church of England
built a chapel on the land,
and Quaw was invited to become
the sexton of the chapel,
becoming the first black sexton
of an Anglican church, anywhere
in the world.
He is now a teacher.
He conducts Sunday
school classes
for the kids on the estates.
In this sense, therefore, Quaw
becomes the first teacher.
He becomes the first teacher
and academic of the Cave Hill
campus.
So we see him as our ancestor.
He is the first to be involved
in the profession of teaching--
and not bad for a child who
was thrown into slavery.
At the age of three,
his parents were killed
in the raid on his village.
And now we memorialize
Quaw on the campus.
And in the background
there of that symbol,
are plates made of
fiberglass with the names
of all of the enslaved persons
who worked on the soil that
is now the Cave Hill campus.
And these are the list of all
of those enslaved Africans,
where they were born, whether
in Africa, in Barbados,
and other islands
of the Caribbean,
their names, their profession,
their color, all of that.
So we have all of these lists--
males and females, children,
boys and girls.
And we see Quaw there
at emancipation.
These are the huge books
that carry their names
so that students can
leave the classroom,
go to Quaw's monument, and see
the journey of their ancestors
on that space that
is now the campus.
And why do we call
it Quaw's Quest.?
He died in the cholera
epidemic of 1854.
And while in his
last hours of life,
he gave his testimony
to the local priest.
And he said, well, I was
brought here as a child
without a family.
Now, I'm a teacher.
I'm a free man.
I have a wife.
I have four children.
My quest is complete.
And so, we call this
monument Quaw's Quest.
But we did not end
there in this process
of engaging the environment
and rehabilitation.
We did not end there.
Six years ago, the task--
it was my responsibility to
construct a new administration
building on the campus.
I assembled a team
of architects.
And I said, OK, we are now
going to build a facility
on this campus that represents
the administrative function
of the institution.
And we thought-- why not design
our administration building
with the architectural motif
of the African golden stool,
the golden stool of the Ashanti.
The golden stool of the
Ashanti, the first rebellion
on the island of Barbados--
the first attempt
at revolt was 1675.
An Ashanti man by
the name of Kofi
was meant to become
the king of Barbados.
He destroyed the slave
owners, destroyed slavery.
Kofi was going to be installed
in a ceremony of state,
and he would become
King Kofi of Barbados
in classical Ashanti fashion.
They had a stool made of wood.
And he was meant to be installed
on the 12th of June, 1675,
when the revolt had succeeded.
Well, they did not succeed.
Kofi was beheaded
and burnt alive,
he and all of his followers.
And the stool they had made
of wood for this ceremony
was also burnt.
We took the decision--
the bold decision-- of
giving King Kofi his stool.
And now Barbados,
the Cave Hill campus,
on a land built for
slavery and plantation,
now the home of the campus,
King Kofi of the Ashanti
now has his golden stool.
And there we go, the
golden stool of King Kofi.
When this structure
was completed,
the vast majority of
people in Barbados
assume it was a
Chinese building.
So detached were the
citizens from their history,
their Ghanaian roots-- and the
vast majority of the Africans
on the island are from
what we now call today--
or what was called
then the Gold Coast.
The majority were
Ashantis, Gas, and Fantes.
This would have been a common
symbol for their ancestors.
Their ancestors would
have known immediately
what this represented, but
the descendants do not-- so
detached they are from
their history, so detached
they are from their
historical, cultural roots,
which is fundamentally one
of the crimes of slavery,
to be detached from your roots.
And now, the schoolchildren come
to the campus on a weekly basis
to receive historical lessons
in their African history
and culture, and to
understand the significance
of this structure as a
proud symbol on a campus
where thousands of enslaved
Africans worked and died.
And allow me to
say in conclusion
that we didn't end there
with the management
of the physical environment--
our teaching, our research,
our public advocacy, our
professional training.
We engaged this
history every day.
Our university
sees itself as part
of that mandate to clean
up the legacies of slavery.
All we do, we confront it.
We engage it.
We are cleaning this up--
whether it's in the area
of public health, diabetes,
hypertension, whether it's
the issues of anti-poverty,
all the issues, all the
legacies of slavery.
This university engages
these legacies daily.
This is where our
resources are allocated.
And we have taken
one final step.
Three months ago, the
University of the West Indies
established the Institute
for Reparations Research.
This institution comees
in against the background
of the establishment
of the Caribbean
Commission for Reparations.
We are going to construct
the evidentiary basis
for the reparatory
claim, which will
be made against all
of those in power
and institutions and governments
of Western Europe, including,
of course, the financial
institutions, all
of those who were
criminally enriched
in this process of enslavement.
And so, this institute is
seen as a critical step
towards the process of
developing a social justice
pedagogy within the university.
And we really do hope it will
be a part of a global network
of similar institutions
that will help us to move
this conversation forward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- So we have now live from South
Africa, Vice Chancellor Price,
who will speak to us
live for a few minutes.
Can you hear us?
- I can, indeed.
Can you hear me?
- Yes.
We hear you.
- Thank you very much.
Thank you, and I enjoyed--
let me greet you and greet
Sir Hilary and Madame Taubira.
Thank you all for
the opportunity.
And thank you, President
Faust, for the opportunity.
I was connected
already to listen
to the video of my presentation.
And I thought I would--
I had understood I needed to
speak only for 10 minutes.
So thank you for giving me
just a few more minutes.
As I watched my own
video, I realized
that in the short time, there
was a risk of over-simplifying
a number of issues.
And so, the opportunity
just gives me--
it gives me an opportunity to
highlight some nuances that I
didn't.
The first was in talking
about de-colonization
and coloniality, of course,
the key challenge is,
what constitutes the colonial?
What constitutes the
colonial in, say, artworks--
which, as we know,
belies the way
in which contemporary
artworks are
the sum of inferences from many
heritages and many sources.
And so that when one comes to
grappling with what it means
to de-colonize an
environment, that becomes,
of course, hugely contested,
and there aren't easy answers.
I think, as I presented it,
it sounded a whole lot simpler
than that.
The second, I think,
is that students do not
speak with one voice.
There are many different
views-- and certainly
many different views
amongst black students.
There are many
black students who
would say of artworks
that the purpose of art
is to move one out of
one's comfort zone.
So while there will be some
who will feel and take offense,
others will say that's
what art is about.
And so, then who gets to
decide on a campus as diverse
as we are, and as one would
expect to find in a country
like South Africa?
Who gets to decide
then, and how does one
resolve what it means to be
an inclusive environment?
This relates from
everything-- architecture,
names of buildings, artworks,
curricula, role models.
I think with respect
to some of these,
one of the lessons we've learned
as the debates have proceeded
is that as much of it resides
in the question of curation
and curation policy, as in
the artworks themselves.
And that is often not
any individual artwork
that is the problem,
but the sum of them,
and how they are presented and
often decontextualized or not
sufficiently contextualized.
And the final
point-- thank you--
that I'd like to add with the
extra minute offered is that
in reflecting on my
talk, I think, again,
I was in a shorthand
trying to highlight--
it would have come across
as a significant rupture
from the pre-Rhodes
[INAUDIBLE] period
to the post-Rhodes [INAUDIBLE]
period, as if prior to Rhodes
there was no debate
or no consciousness
of this coloniality
and no challenge of it,
perhaps even a pride in a
particular dominant culture.
And that wouldn't be correct.
Over many decades, in
fact, those debates
have been going on.
And it's an interesting
question too,
but separate from this
discussion about why this
suddenly bubbled over in 2015
and what the national dynamics
were and the global dynamics.
But there were certainly plenty
of debates going on before.
Perhaps the key shift was the
success of transformation,
that the number of black
students and black faculty
in the university had reached
a critical mass where that--
what was a hegemonic
culture-- could be more easily
challenged, where people
found their voice--
not only as individuals who
had always found their voice,
but as collectives--
which surfaced the issues in
very graphic and sometimes
violent forms, and has resulted
in the protest movements
we've seen over
the last two years.
But thank you, again,
for the opportunity
to add a few comments.
And I look forward
to the discussion.
- Thank you, Max.
So we have limited
time left, and I'm
going to try to summarize
some of the questions.
We have received a few from
the different audiences,
including some from
Twitter, which apparently
can be used for good purposes.
And you know that.
And I'm going to
start with a question
that I think can
actually be addressed
by all of our panelists.
And the question
reads as follows.
Madame Taubira spoke of how
France's centralized governance
made action possible.
Can each of you reflect on
the differences between action
that comes from the
top and action that
begins at the grassroots?
How are these forms different?
- I'll try to answer
with my English.
- Your English is impeccable.
- That is a light luggage.
I do believe that
it's very important
that the citizens feel concerned
by this topic, because it's
about their lives, their
history, our history, our past.
But let's go.
Let's watch-- what
was this past?
It was public organization--
states, public companies.
It was a monarchical time.
Maybe I must thank the
Consul General de France.
He maybe will help me
between French and English?
And I see him.
I see that the
ambassador is there, too.
I'll try to explain.
Slave trade and slavery
were organized by the state.
It was a public activity.
The societies were organized
around this activity.
It was a main economic activity.
And moreover, there was at this
time in the European countries,
there were every time wars
between them, every time.
The countries were
not still stabilized.
And all of them agreed that when
they have a conflict, they call
the Pope, the
Vatican, no [FRENCH]
And the Pope was the one
who said the king here
and the king here who
are fighting, you stop.
Because I say that,
you, I give you that.
You, I give you that.
That's what happened
between Spain and Portugal
when the Pope decided the
Tordesillas Treaty, which
divided South America--
not only South America, South
America and Africa, too--
divided the west for Portugal--
and the east for the Portugal
and the west for Spain.
So that's the way it was
working at this time--
the government, the
monarchy, the Pope.
So today, when we
deal with this issue,
we can't just do it between
citizens, between associations,
between--
we need that public power
say something about it,
organize a few things about it--
such as teaching in the
schools and the university,
and helping researchers,
teachers to make research
and to help us to understand,
to know very well,
and to understand.
Not to be irked by that,
but to feel stronger--
to feel stronger, to understand
that we are survivors,
that we're invincible.
I should say that
we are immortal.
How do you say this is English?
Immortal.
It's OK.
Generation from generation,
we are immortal.
That means that we grow
stronger, stronger,
and stronger--
so next generation, stronger
than the former one.
That's a rarity of this history.
So we need the implication of
the states to organize that,
to make it penetrating
the world society.
That's what I think.
- Thank you.
- Three years ago, the
governments of CARICOM
agreed to confront
this history--
not only in respect of
financial institutions,
academic institutions,
and the legacy of slavery
and colonization,
but to see how they
can play a role in furthering
what is really a civil society
discourse.
Governments had been
reluctant to participate
in this conversation
for a hundred years.
As I said we still in an age in
which the colonial structures
are still very much a part
of the Caribbean world.
My friend here,
I'm from Barbados.
Just 15 minutes away
from Barbados by flight
is Martinique.
You arrive at
Martinique, and there's
an enormous, oppressive
sign at the airport which
says welcome to France.
And we find that
very offensive--
to arrive in the neighboring
island and welcome to France.
That is extremely
horrific for us,
who have fought for
our independence
and who have
established our nations.
Now, so there is
this conversation
of ongoing colonial aggression.
But each time governments
come on board,
they do so not to initiate.
They do so to join an
existing conversation,
where public opinion has
tilted in a certain direction.
And in respect of
confronting this history,
I would say that for the better
part of the 20th century,
the political posture of
most governments-- colonial
and the first generation
of independent states--
was let us forget the
history and move on.
There was this pedagogy
of forgetfulness.
Let us put the past
behind and let us move on.
Civil society was saying no.
But we are living with
this history every day.
We need to deal with it.
The governments were
saying, no, let's move on.
And we had this enormous
rift between civil society
and governments.
Then suddenly, the governments
came on board, because
of a realization that
you're caught in a trap.
You do not want to look back
and you cannot go forward.
And if you cannot move forward
and you don't want to go back,
where are you?
And therein lies
this conversation
that it has to be addressed.
And, therefore,
the question of all
of these institutions--
and not only the
academic institutions
but the churches.
We are living in a world
in which the largest--
some of the largest slave
owners in the Caribbean
were clergymen.
In Barbados, my island,
the largest slave owner
in the decade of emancipation
was a Reverend John Brathwaite,
a well-known theologian.
The Church of England and
its corporate identity
was the owner of 3,000
slaves on the island.
It bought and sold them
in many of thje same ways.
The slaves were stamped C of E--
Church of England, and it was
stamped on their back, Church
of England.
So these are the histories.
And, yes, the academic discourse
is a part, the university
and slavery, the church and
slavery, the banks and slavery,
the industrial
corporations and slavery.
All of these major
institutions in our ecologies
were built upon slavery
and sustained by it.
So this-- the
university and slavery--
is a part, an element of a
wider conversation, which I hope
we can also get to.
- Max, would you like
to add something?
- Thanks.
I'm going to interpret
the question perhaps
a little more in the context
of the theme of slavery
and universities.
And I think one of
the challenges is--
within a university is the
idea of academic freedom
and the autonomy
of universities.
And so, one question is, what
should the role of government
be in relation to
universities when it is--
if it wishes to memorialize, or
to encourage debate, or to push
a particular line?
For example, the law that
we heard passed in France
that every school child should
have in their curriculum
knowledge of the
history of slavery
is certainly an example
of leading from the top
and imposing from the top.
I think that the universities,
in our environment,
would be very reluctant
to be told what they have
to teach and to have a
central government determine
a curriculum.
Now, I know that
the law probably
applies to the schools,
not to universities.
I don't know if that does apply
to the universities in France.
But in trying to answer
your question more directly,
I think that, with
respect to universities,
the question of authority
top-down, the autonomy
of universities and the
issues of academic freedom
raise other issues,
which for me are
very precious, core to the
values of these institutions.
And so, I would not
want to see that kind
of central authority exercised.
And, in fact, I think
it trickles down
within the institution, too.
And part of the challenge for
all of us as university leaders
is that you can't--
it's not easy to lead
from the top, in the way
you march in a
corporate environment
or in a political
environment, to say
we will transform the
curricula in this way,
or we will de-colonize
in that way,
or we will reflect
our relationship
with slavery in the other.
Because academics themselves
value and treasure
the autonomy to teach
what they want to teach,
and who they want to teach,
and how they want to do that.
And so, I think that the
role of university leadership
has to be much more one of
mobilizing, and persuasion,
and cajoling, and building a
consensus, building a movement.
Certainly, if we look
at how, in our own case,
the debates around Rhodes--
the Rhodes statue and other
examples that I gave--
some have not been
successful, because we
haven't been able to
build sufficient support.
Some quickly caught on.
Many of the successes
have become successes
because they started as
grassroots activities, which
gathered support, found a
sympathetic ear, I think,
[? here ?] in most
cases, but could not
have been successful if it
wasn't a dialectical process.
- I think I have a
slightly different approach
to this issue.
In our university's
charter, there
is reference to the
institution being
expected to be not only
excellent but also ethical.
And within this discourse of
been excellent and ethical,
and we have focused,
generally speaking,
as university administrators
on the discourse about been
excellent and all of the
quality assurance systems
we put in place, and we
invest significant resources
in the trajectory
towards excellence.
But we tend to get
a bit soft, I think,
around how we interpret
the ethical part.
Now, I believe that, in
respect of slavery, that--
and colonization, apartheid,
and all of these other crimes
against humanity, we have
exercised a very low level
of expectation.
And it has always been
strange to me why,
in respect to many of the
crimes of the 20th century--
for example, we
showed a level of rage
and we don't show the
corresponding rage in relation
to slavery.
I do not believe that
any president or provost
in this country would accept
a monument of a Nazi general
on their campus.
I believe that if you
examine the economic history
of this country--
and in the first phase
of nation-building,
all of the monuments of King
George and the British generals
were taken down--
the Duke of Portland,
the Duke of Marlborough,
all of these British
warmongers, all these generals
were taken down from
the public spaces,
taken down from the public
squares and from the campuses.
Because the nation
was emerging and it
was intolerant of
British imperial symbols.
Even the game I love, cricket,
was removed from this country.
Because Abraham Lincoln
said I have no doubt cricket
is a greater game than
baseball, but alas, it
will not serve our purposes.
It is a British
colonial product.
It must go.
So all of that took place in the
first stage of nation-building.
Now we come to this stage
and all the monuments
of the slave owners are there.
Why is there this tolerance?
Why did we-- why are we
tolerating slave owners
on our campuses and
we don't tolerate
British imperial
generals on our campuses?
Why did we take down King
George and we cannot take down
Jefferson?
Why is that so?
If we confront that
fact and we say,
OK, this is the second phase
of American nation-building.
Let us now look at how we
deal with our environment.
Those who say take
down the monuments
are not doing something
for the first time.
This is the second phase of
the monument's discussion.
And the first phase
was very effective.
I think that sometimes we
hide behind our prejudices
and we find very skillful
academic reasons to say
we must not act.
We must not act, we cannot act
because academic freedom, blah,
blah, and so on.
Which I respect,
but the threshold
is always oftentimes
too low on the questions
of the black history.
We set a low threshold.
I would not be a part
of a conversation that
would defend Jewish--
defend those persons
who committed atrocities
against the Jewish people.
I would not have those
monuments on my campus.
I don't think my students would.
Those persons who
committed crimes
against the African
peoples by enslaving them,
that is the same threshold,
the same level of threshold we
hold for those who
committed war crimes
against the Jewish people.
We hold that same
threshold against those
who committed crimes
against the African peoples,
and we keep a common standard.
So I do not accept
this notion that people
like Cecil Rhodes, who was
really, in fact, effectively
a genocidal maniac, really--
people like Cecil Rhodes can
be defended by any principal
or provost that we have
Cecil Rhodes on our campuses
because our intellectual
freedom says let him stay.
I'm sure that if you apply the
same threshold that you have
applied to the Holocaust
against the Jewish people
to the African people, you would
have a different conclusion.
And I say one final
point on this.
When the Nuremberg Trials
were about to commence
and the judges were having
tremendous difficulty
in litigating this crime
against the Jewish people,
there was no precedent
in law for these crimes.
There was no jurisprudence
they could use.
There was no body
of legal thought
to guide them through this.
And they were becoming
a bit disillusioned.
And one of them actually
said, in the midst
of their despair of not
knowing how to proceed,
we are walking into the
desert and somewhere out
there there is water.
Let us go and find it.
And with that metaphor, they
moved through those trials
and brought those
persons to justice.
Now, I believe
that all of us who
are leaders of
university institutions,
we are walking into the desert.
And somewhere in
that desert, there
is an oasis we need to find.
And I think we should brace
ourselves, prepare ourselves,
and walk into the desert.
- Let me move to
the next question.
- No, no, no.
It's very important,
because it's--
- Well, go ahead.
- I'm quite sorry, but yes,
it's about the question
of the government who
says what to teach.
It's not the point.
I mean, what I said, what I
explained about this law that
compels the government
to organize teaching
of this history is not to teach
what the government think.
It's putting the agenda, and
the teachers make their job.
And in the same
article, the government
is compelled to finance
research and cooperation,
in order to know exactly,
to know this history, all
these aspects of this history.
So it's not a government that
decides what people must know,
but to stop not knowing
anything about it, to stop that.
Because it's very
important for people
to know children, and teenagers,
and people to know what
is this history.
Because this history is
the key to understanding
the present world--
the present world.
I mean, just to--
I'm not a Martiniques.
But I'm not sure there
is Martiniques in there.
But let me tell you,
we cannot wonder why--
it seems to me that the chief of
state in your country is still
the [NON-ENGLISH] the
queen of Great Britain,
and your countries, and all
the Caribbean countries belong
to commonwealth.
That's at the 20th and 21st
century, that's the trust.
How do you say trust?
Trust?
- Trust.
- Trust?
Yes, trust of this history.
And I don't think that
stigmatizing a whole people
is a way to escape of the
traces of this history.
There are kinds of links
different between ex-metropolis
and ex-colonies.
And that the way it is, it's a
question of collective destiny.
It's not a question of judgment.
What I think is very
important for the government
to be involved in this history
in teaching the history--
not the content, but the
teaching, and searching,
and knowing more and more.
It's because it's at
the level of a state you
may have the means to
know exactly what it was.
It was violence, sure.
It was violence.
It was quite awful, horrific.
But it was resistance.
It was resilience.
It was creativity.
It was music.
It was art.
It was literature.
It was singing,
joy, and happiness,
and fighting, and
crying, and laughing.
It was all that.
And we have to know it.
We have to invest
in all of that.
We have to know all these people
bring to the world humanity--
languages, new languages,
new religions, new hearts,
and new music--
jazz, blues, rag time, soul,
salsa, calypso, everything.
We have to know that to
understand what we bring.
That's why we are invincible.
But we have to know that.
We have to share it.
We have to give it
to our children.
So I can't do it myself.
An association
can't do it itself.
We need the public means to know
all of this, to know how rich
and how strong we are.
[APPLAUSE]
- I don't think we could
have ended on a better
place than this one.
I want to thank the three
panelists for being with us
today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm sorry.
- I just sent it to ask you
another question, that's all.
- Thank you very
much, Alejandro.
You can take your seats.
Thank you for that fantastic
panel, all three of you--
all four of you.
My name is Dan Carpenter.
And I teach in the government
department here at Harvard,
and I direct the social sciences
academic ventures faculty
director at Radcliffe.
And I want to offer--
before giving some thanks--
two reflections on today, one
personal and one professional.
I learned so much today.
This isn't my field
of study, primary.
But what I learned about
actually my own past
in listening to stories about
Georgetown and other places
was a way of putting together
parts of a larger story.
I grew up in a small
town, a very small town
of about 800 people in Northern
Michigan, entirely white.
I then went to college at
Georgetown in Washington DC.
I then went to graduate school
at the University of Chicago,
the south side of Chicago.
And then my three academic
jobs have been at Princeton--
which we heard a lot
about yesterday--
University of Michigan, and
now, of course, Harvard.
I learned today that
every place along the way
of my own academic journey was
spent at an institution that
supported me, housed me,
educated me, credentialed me,
and that owed its
existence, or its endowment,
or its buildings to
slavery, and/or which
sat amidst, but
comfortably isolated
from structures of
racial oppression
right in its neighborhood.
And I had limited, partial
awareness of these stories
today--
before today, excuse me.
I knew some about
Georgetown's history
when I was there as a student.
I knew a bit about
Chicago's environment
and what Ta-Nehisi Coates
referred to as Rob Sampson's
important research on racial
segregation in Chicago.
I knew something-- many
thanks to Sven Beckert
about the history of Harvard.
But today gave me
the opportunity
to weave these threads
together into a fabric, which
like a wampum belt or maybe
even a [INAUDIBLE] cloth,
I could read.
And what a sobering
reading that is
to know that my entire-- just
my entire educational career
has been spent at a lineage of
institutions supported, funded,
subsidized, structured
by slavery themselves.
And that is one that
I'm going to continue
to read in the months,
and years, and weeks
to come, just as a person,
as a student, as a scholar.
And I hope that today's
conference has given others
the ability to read anew
our past, individual
and collective, our president,
and our universities,
and what they ought to
do with their futures.
I hope, as a professional
remark, and second,
that we can move--
as Ta-Nehisi Coates
said we should--
to forms of reparation,
and that we universities
think more thoroughly, and
elaborately, and specifically
about what to do next.
Let me say as a
political scientist
that I don't think that
conversation about slavery
in the university--
either interrogating its past or
discussing its future repair--
can advance without
consideration of the state.
And here, I am so thankful
that Madame Taubira just stole
my point 10 minutes ago,
and said it far better
than I'm about to
convey it to you now--
the state by which I mean our
government, our political,
judicial, and administrative
institutions, our laws.
As the histories inform us,
slavery prevailed and profited,
in part, because laws defined
bodies of color as property.
And the state
enforced those laws
and legitimated those
bodies rendered as assets.
Expanding the geographies
of slavery with armed force,
and with treaties
and other strategies
of Native American
dispossession,
structuring the contracts
by which slaves were sold,
including the
Georgetown sale of 1838,
and were executed
and made enforceable.
Enslavement was
government, I think, maybe.
Beyond the history, it seems
difficult to think about
repair, given the enormous
weight of slavery and its
legacies-- that Mr.
Coates talked about
in today's keynote--
without considering
the role of powers
that can possibly bear
some of that weight.
Not just the resources but the
authority of our governments
and their ability-- like that
of universities-- to host
and structure free
dialogue must be
brought to any repair effort.
Now, exactly how that
enlistment of the state occurs,
of course, is something
probably for another conference
altogether.
And invite those
far better equipped
and more knowledgeable than I
am to advance that discussion.
I now want to turn to
acknowledge the many people who
made today happen.
The Office of the President
and Provost at Harvard
made the decision to
hold this conference,
and they funded it
and supported it.
I want to thank President Drew
Gilpin Faust and Provost Alan
Garber for putting their
enthusiasm and their commitment
into this event.
Thanks to both of you
for your leadership.
It's not a coincidence, I
think, that this happened.
This event, this committee,
this searching examination
of Harvard's history happened
under the university presidency
of a historian.
And I know, and we all know,
that President Faust has
expressed great
concern and an interest
in issues of racial justice
for her entire life,
going back to her childhood.
So, again, Drew, thank you.
Dean Liz Cohen graciously and
energetically took up the call
from President Faust
and Provost Garber,
and brought her
training and perspective
as herself, a renowned
historian of the United States,
to the event.
And let me just say it is
a privilege and an honor
to work with her.
Sven Beckert and Evelyn
Brooks Higginbotham,
thank you for so much
for your hard work.
You have changed
the conversation
at Harvard and the way that
we think about ourselves.
And it's an honor to have
collaborated with you.
Thanks for bringing a political
scientist along for the ride.
I greatly appreciate it.
Radcliffe Institute,
if I may say--
having spent a number of
years here both as fellow--
is really a wonder to behold,
especially in its ability
to host conferences.
All of the speeches and
conversations you saw today,
and many of the things that
you didn't and that I didn't,
happened because this
institute marshals
such intense and passionate
commitment from many people,
from those who plan, those who
cater, those who broadcast,
those who wire the
event, who clean up.
These people are ably led by
Rebecca Wasserman and her staff
at Radcliffe Institute
Academic Ventures,
by [? Nisha Mongia ?]
and [? Chandra Manning ?]
in the office of the dean.
Thank you also [? Chandra, ?]
who served on the committee--
by [? Jessica Vickland ?]
and her crew in events.
And thanks to the many
speakers and moderators
who gave their time and
talent to our event today.
Finally, thanks to those of
you who listened and entered
into today's dialogue, who
took the time to join us.
The conversation, we
know, will continue.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- It's been an incredible day.
I think we've all been left
with a lot to think about.
And I hope conversations
will only now begin, not end.
But I think it's time to relax,
to have some food and drink.
And you've earned a reception.
So please join us
next door for one.
Thanks again for
coming, and I hope
we'll see you again
soon at the Institute.
[MUSIC PLAYING]